[Música]
en la primavera de 1944 los ciudadanos
de Tokio sufrieron varios ataques aéreos
por parte de los aliados el sonido de
las sirenas los alertaba para que se
refugiaran y anticipaban apagones en la
ciudad pero gizaco koyama de 28 años
veía esos apagones como oportunidades
con un futón en su cabeza como
protección koyama contemplaba el cielo
nocturno buscando todo tipo de fenómenos
astronómicos sin embargo para su último
intento necesitaba la luz del día al
apuntar su telescopio hacia el Sol
coyama podía plasmar la luz de las
estrellas en una hoja de papel lo que le
permitía hacer un boceto de la
superficie cambiante del sol pasó
semanas recreando este método y
registraba cada cambio que observaba
pero aunque koyama no lo supiera estos
diseños eran el comienzo de uno de los
registros más importantes de la
actividad solar en la historia de la
humanidad para entender por completo
en la superficie del sol primero
necesitamos entender lo que sucede
dentro de la Estrella cada segundo
billones de moléculas de oxígeno se
fusionan con moléculas de helio en un
proceso llamado fusión nuclear
esta explosión continua mantiene la
temperatura interna del Sol de
aproximadamente 15 millones de grados
Celsius lo que es más que suficiente
energía para transformar gas en agitados
charcos de plasma
el plasma consiste de partículas
cargadas que generan poderosos Campos
magnéticos pero a diferencia de las
partículas cargadas y estables que
mantienen la actividad magnética de la
tierra este plasma está en constante
movimiento alterando y aumentando el
campo magnético del sol
[Música]
este movimiento continuo puede generar
concentraciones temporales de actividad
magnética que inhiben el movimiento de
las moléculas y terminan reduciendo el
calor en el área y ya que las zonas con
menos calor generan menos luz los
lugares con Campos magnéticos más
fuertes aparecen como manchas oscuras
esparcidas en la superficie del sol
estas manchas solares están siempre en
movimiento como resultado del plasma que
se mueve dentro de la Esfera y de la
rotación del Sol y ya que suelen
aglomerarse contar y rastrear el
movimiento de las manchas puede ser todo
un desafío que depende en gran medida de
la percepción y juicio del observador
esto es justamente lo valioso de las
contribuciones de koyama a pesar de no
tener una formación en astronomía sus
observaciones y bocetos fueron
asombrosamente precisos después de
enviar su trabajo a la asociación
astronómica Oriental recibió una carta
de reconocimiento por sus detalladas
observaciones con este apoyo comenzó a
visitar el museo de ciencias de Tokio
donde pudo usar un mejor telescopio para
continuar con su trabajo
koyama pronto formó parte del personal
del museo como observadora profesional y
Durante los siguientes 40 años trabajó
todos los días en más de 10.000 bocetos
de la superficie solar
Los investigadores ya sabían que las
corrientes magnéticas del sol seguían un
ciclo de 11 años en el que las manchas
solares seguían un camino con forma de
mariposa pero al usar el registro de
koyama pudieron seguir con precisión
manchas y grupos específicos en ese
recorrido este nivel de detalle ofreció
una indicación en tiempo real de la
actividad magnética solar lo que les
permitió a los científicos rastrear todo
tipo de fenómenos incluidas las
volátiles erupciones solares estas
erupciones suelen emanar de los
alrededores de las manchas solares y
pueden llegar a la atmósfera de la
tierra aquí pueden crear tormentas
geomagnéticas capaces de interrumpir
comunicaciones de larga distancia y de
provocar apagones las erupciones solares
son un riesgo para satélites y
estaciones espaciales lo que hace
imprescindible poder predecirlas y
rastrearlas en una entrevista en 1964
coyama lamentó que sus 17 años de
observación apenas hubieran alcanzado
para crear un solo registro del ciclo
solar en forma de mariposa Pero al final
de su carrera había creado bocetos de
tres ciclos y medio uno de los mayores
registros de la historia Mejor aún la
calidad de sus bocetos era tan
consistente que los usaron como
referencia para reconstruir los últimos
400 años de la actividad de las manchas
solares desde varias fuentes históricas
este proyecto extendió el legado de
koyama Más allá de su vida y demuestra
que la ciencia no solo se crea con
increíbles descubrimientos sino también
con una observación meticulosa del mundo
que nos rodea
si cubrimos el desierto del Sahara en
paneles solares podría El poder del sol
resolver nuestra crisis energética
descúbrelo con este video y suscríbase a
nuestro canal para aprender algo nuevo
cada semana